OK 那个我要不就直接开始吧
然后那个整个市场变化
我我刚刚打开说
看了大概给大家看了一个游戏
Victoria 3
我觉得今年特别是接下去几个月吧
多花点时间玩玩游戏
多花点时间就是做做自己喜欢做的事情
然后呢少花点时间去操作
操作市场特别是去抄底
或者呢就是这个就做多做控
这个市场是一个波动非常非常大的市场
然后接下去几个月
我们会面临更大的tell risk
我们说那个微波风险微波风险没有解锁
微波风险可以往上也可以往下
这个市场其实不确定性很大
因为现在的整个市场的这个下跌的过程
它和过去几次都不一样
甚至和08年这种都不一样
它的下跌过程是一个完全人为政策制造的市场
所以它政策制造市场
它也可以随时给你取消掉
它也可以搞一个更大的市场
更大的政策
就是它比方说它给90天的grease period
那现在我们看下来就昨天开始下跌
所以现在看下来可能很多的政策
你你不确定性会更强
你举个例子
那个你举个例子
比方说昨天说来说那个墨西哥
没有关税政策跟美国没有达成协议对吧
然后日本没有达成协议
那么市场就会继续下跌
所以有没有一种可能
比方说现在中国说对于所有美国跟着美国
就战队美国可能会制裁中国
或者是给中国加关税的国家
中国要反制关税
所以使得比方说欧洲
包括日本包括韩国这些国家
如果要给中国加关税
他们会再次考虑国内的通胀
所以这个问题就是特朗普引起了一个
全球法国内的混战
就关税的混战
在这个过程中结果是怎么样是不太确定的
你可以说很长期的结果
两年三年的结果
因为我们毕竟有AI
然后美国毕竟是pro-business
然后可以说我们可能会看到一个
相对来说比较光明的结果
那在两三年的周期里面可能会看得到
应该是两三年周期是个比较光明的结果
但是你在几个月的周期里面
他经济到底会不会衰退
衰退到哪里
然后FAT会干什么事情
我这里挂了一个猫的坨
Tom & Jerry 坨
就是上周最大的一个焦点
就是美联储对于这件事情的态度
美联储现在也是一头霧水
不知道你要怎么样
所以他也不能采取任何政策
那在这个过程当中
他是会两头杀
然后很大的波动
然后我觉得通缩就是衰退的概率会更大
然后市场现在没有到底
这是我基本的一个判断
那么当然了
这个判断是基于现在的关税政策的
因为Trump这个人的本质
他是一个不太愿意认错的人
那么这个不太愿意认错的人
现在面临的是所有
他想让大家占变美国的国家
要么就是口识经费
要么就是没有办法直接占变
所以在4月2号的两个月
就是7月2号
那个差不多7月2号的节点上面
中间会有很多的变数
很多的你看上去比较说变成了10%
那那些关税有可能会加过来
他现在说Trump是一个probusiness的一个
一个行政 一个一个一个政党
就GOP is probusiness的
但是在probusiness之前
他现在要重述美国对外贸易的一个体系
这个体系建立了100年
那爱战之后一直是一个自由贸易的一系
他要重述这个体系
他觉得所有东西是一个
他不理解贸易这个东西是互惠的
就是你生产更多的
就是economic 101
你生产更多的这个低端生产品
我生产更多的这个高端的这个科技
然后我们是互利
他不理解这个事情
他理解所有东西
就是要么你赢
要么就我赢
Zero some game
这是他的他的体系
所以你要把这个变成Zero some game的话
那就是在美国贸易体系里面
原来的这个全球化的贸易体系
要做一个大的手术
我觉得他做不成
但是呢在在尝试的过程是一个很痛苦的
所以我建议大家做做自己喜欢做的事情
然后多看看游戏多玩玩游戏
不要把过去几年就是那个
不知道怎么赚的钱
然后这几年认认真真的得输掉
好吧
那个上周最大的news还是J-PAL
那么J-PAL在那个一个interview里面
他讲了一句话
就是人家问到他
这个fabput是不是有fabput
就是market expect fabput
你是怎么看
J-PAL的回答是说no with explanation
那是明确的说没有fabput
那个我不会为现在的政策买单
那为什么没有呢
我先分析一下就是他的这个原因
我觉得原因很简单
第一个美联储对于政策
对于白宫政策是不确定的
他不知道你的这个关税政策
到底会搞成什么样
你是不是明天又给我全部取消了
那我的这个政策是
而且白宫是现在是希望给市场一个不确定性
但是美联储长期以来
从greenspan以后
一直是希望给到市场一个确定性
所以他他不确定你白宫要搞什么时候
他不能够先动
你一定要先把你白宫exactive branch的这个政策
确定了以后
我分析这个政策
对于经济实际会造成什么样的影响
在这个影响上面
我再去施加我的政策
所以这个事我觉得联储
不光是执行票个人
就跑出他个人之外
其实所有的执行委员
我觉得是几乎是一致的
这个是一致性的
那么这些执行委员
你说他们的屁股坐在哪里
最近因为川普一直在慢骂
其实川普在那个
出social上面已经开始慢骂那个执行票
然后就是在他自己的社交媒体上
已经慢骂他们
那么这个不光是执票的问题
其实我觉得所有的执行委员
其实第一个屁股都是往左边坐的
第二就是他们的这个传统上来说
他不能够认可那瓦罗那些国师们
随时抛出来的这个政策
甚至像财政部长这些人
都被隔离在这个主要决策以外的
这样的一个政策
他们不能认可他
而且你既然出这样的政策
那我等你政策住干净
你到底要干嘛
然后我再去做决策
这是第一个原因
第二个原因
从本质上来说
J-PAL非常怕
就是保卫非常怕
美联储再次重复70年的错误
就是现在通胀是被压下来了
但是通胀被压下来以后
他非常怕通胀回头
那这个过程就不是半年一年
你哪怕这个半年里面忍受了振痛
但是通胀没有回头
那么我们后面去送开手
那个美联储的政策
政策空间工具箱是很多的
但是如果让那个通胀螺旋反复的话
那么这个过程可能就要拖
一旦通胀上去
那又是两年三年
就是这个过程会拖很长时间
所以我们比较绞完过程
就是您可忍受一些振痛
不要再发生大的错误
这个是我觉得J-PAL最重要的两点
那么第三个就是可能更加Personal
更加斯文一点
对于J-PAL来说
它已经工程名就了
它不太需要这份工作
它明年4月份就要卸任
所以明年4月份
川普肯定不会再用它了
然后它年纪也挺大了
然后那个对于它来说
它最大的它需要的是生后名
就是这一任美联储主席
对抗那个COVID做了非常好
然后及时的甩出了政策
把在COVID中的经济崩溃的边缘拉回来
虽然后面造成了通胀
造成美国历史上
就是几十年以来最大一个通胀
但是以极快的速度把它修复
其实J-PAL做的非常好它的工作
然后修复了以后
然后让美国经济在增长的情况下
没有像Volker这样粗暴的
把经济增长给打断了
然后在经济维持增长的情况下
把通胀给压下来
它到去年年底就是这个评价
是非常好的评价
它不能够忍受后面
我让通胀再次失控一个愚蠢的美联储主席
这个是它不能忍受的
所以它愿意忍
哪怕我现在它忍住这个锅不在它的头上
这个锅在川普头上
市场以后会评论
这个经济本来经济增长很好
然后通胀也被压制住了
那个美联储主席J-PAL、POWER和YELLEN
两个人就是双方的政策的配合
然后被川普给打断了
然后川普造成一个严重的衰退
这个对J-PAL一点过没有
所以这个第三点是它有一些私信的
所以它不会
我觉得它不太会去为那个
特朗普去买单
川普去买单
那么可能还有一个例外的一个原因
就是我现在放出了
如果放出流动性
我降了息
或者按照川普希望的我降息
把美国利息降下来
然后让你政治上加分
因为降了息的话
那个赤字自然就减少了
你那个利息支出变小了
对吧
所以比方说我现在降了息
帮你川普擦了屁股
其实你的政策乱振
导致经济市场跌了很多
我来给POT给了东西
出了问题以后通胀如果上来
是我J-PAL没有控制好
这个没有任何通胀上来
是没有人是会怪Executive Branch的
其实包括上一次通胀上升
你也跟J-PAL没有任何的关系
不是美联储放前放出来的
是财政部给了很多补贴
财政部把这个钱直接注入到市场上
给人家消费
然后造成了通胀
那么以前美联储印了这么多次
从前从安卫的通胀过
那为什么这一次就是那个疫情的手通胀
疫情的通胀其实是财政部造成的
但是市场就会灌美联储
一样的
这次他如果帮那个特朗普擦屁股
擦出问题就是他的问题
然后好的全是Trump
他没有必要去干这个事情
而且现在政策这么不确定
而且我现在帮你擦了屁股
那个Trump会有更大的政策空间瞎搞
现在已经瞎搞了
他可以搞得更厉害一点
所以从这几个角度来说
我觉得J-PAL现在给出的这个回答
其实是非常正确的
就是告诉你现在告诉市场
让市场哪怕短期里面震痛一下
告诉市场没有put
我现在他怎么说的
说说未来降息
其实就说未来降息
要说更高的stretch hold
就是更高的门槛
然后他要保持利息政策的一贯性
对现代利率很满意
我问问他
好
现在虽然有双向风险
但是他要等到hard data变差
就是硬的数据变差
这个和2019年的时候
那个19年那个特朗普的吹窝的时候
也不一样
19年的时候
他没有说要等hard data变差
那个那个时候
那个美联储是配合Trump政策的
现在这一次其实联储是完全不配合Trump政策
所以我们会看到未来几个月
你要hard data变差
那这个东西要两三个月以后了
就是我给一个大概的时间点
我觉得至少要两个月
五月份降息概率几乎为零
那不可能
为什么呢
因为他叫hard data变差
意味着他需要失业率上升
失业率上升到4.5以上
比方说这个是狗们给的
这边是狗们给的这个失业的focus
这个GDP的focus
我们看一下失业率
失业率好像没有没有贴上来
但是你比方说
按照这个狗们给的GDP的focus
他真正要下来的话
按照这个这个
他还是高盛给的
还是相对来说比较
嗯比较乐观的
我觉得比我的要给的数据乐观挺多的
就说那个真正的数据下来
至少二到三几度
那为什么呢
因为很简单
你现在
我们看到的真正差的数据是什么
是前瞻性的数据
那比方说这个帝国
就MPI survey对吧
Fedadofian survey
然后consumer sentiment
那这些数据其实都很差
就是相当于是我前瞻性的数据很差
但是我现在的retail
retail sales不差的
consumer spending也不差的
那个现在数据的混乱在于两个方向
第一个方向就是所有公司
特别是公司层面
资本支出capax投资显著降温
这是一个因为资本市场不好嘛
所以大家显著降温
第二个呢
就是有很多经济数据是规避关税在抢跑
那比方说我补存货啊
然后消费啊
我买东西
那我后面关税我买的贵的
我先买便宜
我先先买啊
然后那个那个企业的采购啊
那这些数据看上去就是又很好
所以他的数据处于一个混乱的状态状态
那个中国的数据也同样
才有有点混乱
4月份以前的那个出口数据就很好
那么所以导致这两个月
从现在开始往后两个月数据是不清晰的
在有一些层面上面比方说
consumer spending啊
这些数据会表现不错的
那真正这些数据要要全部反映出
他可能的关税政策的时候
可能要到6月份
6月份只是反映出他关税的政策
还没有反映出他关税政策的影响的衰退
你要真正的资本
真正的这个比方说
consumer spending这些数据要下去
要关税政策导致失业上升
失业上升导致收入下降
然后再回到那个retail sales
这些东西上面是需要时间的
那么呃像拱门预期
就这你可以看一个趋势
其实大家预期的就是呃
投行们的预期其实都差不多
那么都是预期比方说到现在来看的话
这个东西只能做切线
就是按照现代政策来做切线
呃做一个最好的预测
那么就是四季度和一季度
这个经济实体可能会到底
经济实体到底
你可以认为经济实体真正到底的时候
差不多市场
就真正到底之前吧
差不多市场会到底
所以你会认为市场要到四季度
那才能够到底
那这个是大咖喱会发生的事情
哪怕最最悲观的
像高盛这种最悲观的
现在预期
也就是45%的衰退的概率
但是45%的衰退的概率
其实是远远不够
那呃美联储真的降息
他也只能在6月份
长事情的降一次
后面可能再长事情的降一次
但是呢
我们会觉得
我会觉得那个
如果说经济数据真的变差
就是我们来看美联储什么时候
这个算数当然很高
现在不太会降
6月份的话
数据稍微差一点
他强跑性的降一次
但是什么样的情况下
可以认为是美联储真正开启降息
或者说
明年在一季度的时候
在今年四季度
明年一季度的时候
通胀数据不会很好
通胀可能三年级
然后那个经济数据又变很差
你经济比较说已经到了零
到了一
这个时候他在失业和通胀里面
他会怎么选
就是在这种情况下
就我们前瞻的时间比较长一点
在今年比较说年纪的时候
他会怎么去选
我觉得在这种情况下
他会去选失业
不会去选通胀
这个我
这个是我对美联储的一个理解
不管是节票也好
或者是明年四季四月份以后
新的联储主席也好
都会去选失业
也就是他会无视通胀
认为通胀是短期的
然后把利息降下来
而且这个时候
降息的速度会非常快
他看到经济比方说
通胀通胀率跑到4.5以上
那么他无视比方说
失业率跑到4.5以上
他可以无视通胀
他认为通胀是你连处
是你白宫政策早造成
但是他不是螺旋性的
就是不是工资上涨
通胀上涨
然后工资又上涨
通胀又上涨
这东西螺旋性的上涨
他认为不是
只是输入性的通胀
你是一次性的
他就可以快速降息
他甚至可以降50个点
以前还降过1%
他都可以这样讲
所以你说
虽然现在讲到
那个J-PAL说
他的PUT不在
他是不想你去瞎折腾
但是实际PUT会不会在
我觉得实际PUT是在的
但是只是这个PUT的
这个strike比较低
或者是他strike参考的
不是股票的指数
不是你们这些资本市场
他参考的是真正的失业率
那么等失业率真的上去以后
我相信是会让联储里面
所有的就是各派们全部站起来
现在大家其实说穿了
整个美国体制里面
所有人都在看特朗普白戏
包括看他的戏
包括其实他自己的那个
M-Initiation-Z的这个政策里面
有一些人也是这个样子
另外他的政策研究委员会里面
几个人包括纳瓦罗那些
你对比中国
就是中国的送红兵司马兰和金灿荣
就这种人
所以他出的政策能够实施了财怪
就没有可实施性
你现在跑去那个关税
你去怎么征收
怎么征收都不知道
你怎么看原产地
然后那个征收完以后
那个其他政策谁去谈
其实很多国家说了不好听
很多国家要跟美国谈
跟谁谈
跟JD Vance谈
比方说现在印度和那个
印度区跟JD Vance去谈
你跟谁谈
你跟财政部长谈还是跟副总统谈
副总统应该是一个
是一个标志不是一个执行者的人
所以他处于一个混乱的状态
这么多国家
哪些关税谁的政策
然后谁要去谈成什么样的条件
都是一旁混税
那么这种政策里面
很多政策
包括很多的这个行政部门
比方说FOMC
那其实像JPOW
他是不会去行动的
就是在这个情况下
就是看你百姓
你就可以看
像TOM一样往下掉下来
FOMC是不会救你的
然后看你到哪一步
然后再做最后的决策
那么但是这个过程当中
我觉得最近市场一个比较encouraging
比较我觉得比较乐观的信号
很多人觉得是一个非常悲观的事情
就是美国国债在跌
美元在跌
美国的acquity在跌
这三个一起跌
这个被认为是过去这么长时间以来
从08年以后
其实其实从05年08年以前也是这样子
就是资产配置不停的倾向于美国
比率越来越高
因为美国是通过资本流露
然后投资带动的资本流露
来抵冲它的这个
percent deficit
抵冲它的那个经常性项目的
经常性项目的支出
我做了
我们有很多的那个
美国有很多的贸易十字
但是贸易十字钱流出去了
那么通过投资再回到美国
更因为更好的公司
那个美国增长的两大engine
最大两个engine
一个是公司的margin
所有公司的margin
包括互联网公司
包括所有的这个各种各样的企业
一直到starbox到cosco到那个woma
包括互联
包括谷歌
包括meta
就是说中国
两说你会觉得有些科技公司赚钱
他们的margin跟美国不在一个水平线上
包括你说的华为
美上市的
包括这个阿里安什么腾宣
他们的margin
毛利率和美国公司
不在一个
不在一个维度上
这个是美国第一个最大的力量
所以这个带动他的资本市场
那么资本市场
涨中国美国的household
其实从资本市场上获得了很多好处
再加上这些公司的margin高码
所以他的美国付的工资也高
那就是美国人的收入就高
收入高 资本市场好
household balance也非常好
所以公司的margin和household balance
就是私营部门个人的资产负责表
可能有钱说穿了
这个是美国两个最大的增长的引擎
这个和你那个美国制造
也不知道也没有一毛钱的关系
但是现在的tariff关税政策
其实本质上的影响了这两个引擎
让美国在降温
但是降温的过程中间
资金其实大家在定价资金流出美国
所以美元在贬值
然后USD 美国国债
人家觉得因为你搞了关税的
没有那么多外国投资
人需要美国国债
所以国债在国债利率再上升
然后美国股票再下跌
但是我认为这为什么
我认为这个不是一个特别悲观的事情
因为没有发生金融系统性的问题
一旦金融系统性的问题
或者是没有发生
违约性的问题
包括对冲基金的违约 平仓
没有发生这些事情
一旦这些事情如果发生的时候
应该你会看到一个逆向的
就是所有资产在跌
美元在涨
美国国债在涨
你会不会看得到
一定会看得到
就是没有一次经济危机
现在当然美国所有的银行金融体系
它都非常健康
包括特别是Silicon Valley Bank倒了以后
硅谷银行倒了以后
美联储给出的信号
就是金融企业不能倒
然后我在任何情况下
都会无条件的去救
给贴线窗口去救它
所以我们没有看到
金融体系内的任何流动性紧缩
短期的里面
我们看到过国债的流动性不足
但是上周以后国债流动性已经恢复了
这个恢复很简单
off wrong的债券
我们看到以前off wrong的债券定价
已经和under wrong的不一样了
那就说明整个国债里面
没有人掏力的钱都没有
他不想去掏力
然后流动性很少
借款成本很高
没有人去做套利
但是off wrong的债券
现在已经全部收益率抹平了
和under wrong都差不多了
所以我们会说现在短期里面
看到过债券市场的流动性不足
一个星期就已经全部平了
所以整个金融体系
没有发生流动性的问题
只是定价资金在流出美国
就是我们看到的定价资金会流出美国
那么这个我认为是相对来说
还没有到最坏的时候
你可以想象是这样的
就是美国的经济其实就是带动全球
它是火车头
当你火车头要掉下去的时候
人是往火车尾去跑的
所以这个就是资金流出美国
美元走弱
然后美国国债走弱
然后美国股票下跌
但是人跑到车厢里是躲不开的
只要美国的
因为全球增长引擎
都是美国的公司的margin
加上美国的household balance
这两样东西带动
这两样东西一旦消失的时候
那么其实没有一个人可以倾免
现在市场上在很奇怪的定价两件事情
就是一个是定价欧洲的投资
欧洲的重新的government expansion
政府的这个开始
第二个定价在香港定价中国的消费
欧洲不太好讲
我觉得也未必搞得定
因为欧洲的这个定价
我之前讲过
欧洲的定价得债利率上升
它衍生的结果就是所有债权利率上升
当所有债权利率上升的时候
欧洲会出欧债危机的
他们的货币体系
跟美国的货币体系不太一样
欧洲养行不一定会去救那些prefery
就是那个病人国家
这是一
第二定价那个中国的消费
在香港定价中国消费
这个更加是个笑话
就说那个中国虽然给了很多消费代
但是中国的本质是
国家会花更多的钱去消费
是有军事或者是国家实力军事方面的影响
它甚至会去买华为那些
就是你知道华为出了一个芯片
这个用计算芯片说要击败英伟达
就是耗费四倍电力
耗费四倍电力它的难度是上四个数量级吧
没有四个数量级 两三个数量级
那个不是简单增加四倍电力就可以
但是国家会花钱花在这个东西上面
以前会花5G 现在会花在这个算力上
但是它没有把钱给到老百姓去做消费
消费是给的消费代
其实这个过程当中最后买单的
是借债的那个方代
就是借债的老百姓
而且现在整个中国的居民杠杆已经太高了
所以我不觉得消费能够划过来
香港在定价这个
然后欧洲在定价那个国家重新消费
这个我觉得其实更像一个Rowing
就掉下去的火车头
这是美国 你往后面车枪跑
肯定是逃不开的
这个是我个人的更加看法
所以我们现在面临的情况
我一直在思索
什么样的情况能够让整个市场重新恢复
就是我们不是说这种短期的反弹
比较说上周这种反弹
还是说一个趋势性的能够让这个市场变好
或者趋势性的扭势
什么样的条件 我没有看到其实
不管是从联储政策上面
或者是从那个Trump的这个Tariff政策
不管他取消到哪一步 我都没有看到
因为Tariff政策的影响已经很深远了
他哪怕回到特朗普认为最低的那些Tariff
他对经济的影响负面的情况
现在都没有完全被定价进去
这个是因为你在衰退的时候
你要定价EPS会变得更低吗
现在EPS增长还是
你像勾门把那个25年的这个经济
已经QE已经定成这样了
他对今年的EPS定价还是在3%
那25年会到多少呢
如果是真的衰退
如果25年衰退两个季度呢
就说真正的如果是掉到下面的零以下
衰退两三个季度呢
那25年是不是EPS要-5%-10%
所以这些其实我觉得在现在这个
他指数上并没有被定价出来
那么如果没有定价出来呢
我觉得我们的策略呢
就是尽量玩游戏
尽量做一些自己喜欢的事情 玩玩游戏
然后等到这个政策更加明确
然后可能会有可能会有反转
那么如果说非常长期
我对美国还是很乐观
因为你不管怎么影响吧
他相对于全世界其他地方的话
他的这个公司的码诊还是很高
然后household balance sheet
虽然虽然可能会受到经济危机啊
这些影响
但是公司的码诊相对来说
好的公司还都在美国
好到资本市场也在美国
第二呢
Trump现在在重塑他美国的一个贸易政策
那这个过程很痛苦
但是他后面在今年年底明年年初
他还是会补偿性的会给退税的
那给退税政策这是pro-business
Deregulation减少监管也是pro-business
就是他虽然没有长法
但是他的方向呢
就是并不能一板子打死全部是错
那么在经济真正见底
如果是25年真正经济见底的时候
连储的put
像我刚刚讲的连储put和连储给就业的put
和给到那个给到通胀的这个担忧
这两个之间他一定是选就业的
所以有可能这两个政策的交集
又会在什么时候发生
可能还是在25年或者24年年底
我觉得还是有可能会发生的
那么是不是在节票手上
其实这个不重要
不是连储主席的问题
这个还是还是这个他的目标的问题
所以我对于这个政策呢
就是我认为就是美国很多科技公司
虽然跌了很多
那个可能往下的空间和往上空间差不多
但是对于s&p其他成分股
你现在下跌不够
对于那个很多资产流出美国
我们流入黄金啊
这个石油肯定是不能碰到
石油跌了很惨
流入黄金啊
流入比特币啊
流入世界其他地方
我觉得就是复盆之下安有软碗
大家就是可能这两个月还不错
但是一两个月之后
其实这些都会变成一个做空的标底
那么第三呢
就是政策性的回头
或者是美国更加长期的市场
会不会好
我觉得更加长期我是乐观的
因为AI还在那个
包括GOP本质上是pro business
那个GOP本质上pro business
他的那个deregulation啊
或者是deregulation政策退税的政策
和连储可能应对衰退的政策
可能会在明年形成交集
所以在现在不明情况下情况下
不明情况下的时候
你可以有比较低的仓位
然后你就等着看
但是一定要管住自己的手
不要觉得跌了很多的时候
就是一个铁底去超底
那个美国你不清楚
这一次的衰退是像covid的一样
是短坏
然后有政策脱底短坏
还是像比方说
二二年这样
不 我觉得不太会像二二年这样
但是二二年可以让大家看一下恐怖的情况
就是资金流出美国的趋势
趋势性的流出美国维持一年两年
你不清楚是哪一种情况
虽然最后可能都会回来
就是美国的美国金融市场最后一定会恢复的
但是你不知道它是走哪种情况的话
那我就是建议今年就是
again 忍住
忍住手
不要轻举妄动
然后低仓位可以的
然后如果一定要交易
寻找机会在非美国的地方去做恐
只要它上涨的多的非美国地方
比方说香港比方说
欧洲如果涨很多的话
我觉得都可以
但是
个人建议是一个最好的政策
好吧
那个我简单跟大家沟通一下
然后看看